our subject for this evening held for
the helpless
hell for the helpless good evening
everyone it's morning where i am i'm
looking through a window and there's a
little snow coming down we're in the
winter season here in the united states
but winter spring summer or fall the
power of god is the same
i thank him for this privilege to
fellowship with you
and to bring to you thus saith the lord
it is a tremendous honor to speak for
god
many years ago i read a statement in the
writings of allah white where she said
angels occasionally ask god to let them
speak and preach but god consistently
tells them no and he allows people such
as i and you to preach the gospel so it
is a very high honor for me to be asked
to speak for god and i will do all that
i can to represent him well by simply
presenting
thus said the lord i am very privileged
again to be with you and i pray that god
will bless you beyond your expectation
and your imagination
i welcome you but i also particularly
welcome anyone listening who is not
assembled the evangelist your presence
among us means a lot to us
and we thank you for taking the time for
god and for his word
and those who take time for god god
blesses them in a special way and so
thank you for joining and we hope that
you will join us tomorrow and wednesday
and thursday when we end
for the little boys and little girls who
are watching thank you very much i want
you to know very clearly that god is
always pleased when little boys and
little girls give their lives to him
let me say that again god is delighted
when little boys and little girls give
their lives to him and i saw some little
children in the choir that sang and i
saw a young lady who gave professional
music so i'm sure there are a lot of
little boys and little girls that must
say the third time
god wants you to give your lives to him
and please do that and you will put a
smile on the face of god
i don't know what countries are
represented by those who are listening
but whatever country you're in wherever
you are may the lord bless you may the
lord bless the leadership of those
countries
our subject for this evening help for
the helpless
hell for the helpless before i get into
that message as god has given it to me i
must ask you to do three favors for me
as i did last evening fear number one is
to preserve reverence where you are it
is sometimes easy to forget that we have
assembled to worship the god of heaven
and earth before whom the angels fail
their faces when they come into his
presence so please preserve reference
where you are despite the fact that you
are in the comfort of your home preserve
reverence manage the environment monitor
your children so that god can be
worshipped in spirit uh and in truth and
in reverence favor number two
while i'm speaking pray for me and say
lord
put your words in that man's mouth
when god said moses to speak to pharaoh
in exodus chapter 4 god told them in
verse 12 now therefore go and i will be
with thy mouth and teach thee what thou
shalt say i want god to be with my mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9
then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth and the lord said unto
me behold i have put my words in thy
mouth i want god to put his words in my
mouth
second samuel 23 verse 2
the spirit of the lord spake by me and
his word was in my tongue i want god's
words in my tongue and so from time to
time as i'm speaking simply say in the
privacy of your heart
lord
please
put your words
in that man's mouth and favor number
three
think as you listen god has given us a
mind which separates us from the animals
so that we may think and and reason and
synthesize what we're listening to
isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason
together said the lord in uh jeremiah
chapter 12 verse 5 the bible said if
thou has run with the footmen
and they have weary thee how can then
contend with the horses in other words
god is saying if you cannot keep up with
a man how can you keep up with the horse
he's calling us to reason
reasoning is essential to understand the
bible in uh mark chapter 12 verse 28 the
bible says one of the scribes came and
having heard them read
jesus reasoned with the audience paul
reason all the apostles reason so as you
listen think and allow the spirit of god
to direct that thinking so that he may
now flash the light of truth into your
mind let's pray
dear god in heaven we thank you for life
we thank you god for clear minds
we thank you for freedom of worship
we thank you for knowledge of christ
as we bow in your presence if we have
sinned against you forgive us
father be very deliberate in forgiving
us and washing the sin away leave not
one spot
because sin interferes with our ability
to understand divine truth
grant us your spirit dear god
because you're looking for people who
will worship you in spirit and in truth
and he is the spirit of truth grant us
that spirit because jesus tells us in
john 16 13 i'll be it when he the spirit
of truth is come
he will guide you into all truth
guide me and guide your people that what
i say may make sense to them under the
guidance of your spirit
father bless all the visitors
those who are not seven of the
advertisers touch their lives in a very
special way god particularly their
children
for those who may be sick with covet 19
i ask you to touch them right now dear
god
and remove that affliction father not
simply give them improvement their god
father with careful boldness i ask you
to heal them completely
father several nations may be
represented by those who are listening
bless those nations bless the leaders
for as the leaders go sober the nations
as leaders go so for the churches bless
the leaders father keep them always
aware of the fact
that the most high
ruleth in the kingdoms of men
keep them always conscious of the fact
that righteousness exalted the nation
now dear god i place myself before you
use me father for your glory and your
glory alone i offer this prayer from my
heart in jesus name
amen
our subject
help for the helpless
in the book of acts let's go to the book
of acts chapter 16
we'll read verse 30.
the book of acts chapter 16 we read 30
and 31. you are familiar with the story
paul and silas have been imprisoned for
preaching the truth
preaching the truth will get you into
trouble it did back then it will do now
it will do in the future but we must do
it because the truth must be more
important to us than our very lives i
say that again the truth
must mean more to us than our very lies
in acts chapter 16 reading verse 30 the
phil the jailer at philippi he said the
ball in silence the bible says and he
brought them up and said men sirs what
must i do to be saved and they said
believe on the lord jesus christ and
thou shalt be saved on thy house verses
30 and 31 observe the question from the
philippian jailer what must i do
to be saved
not what must i do to save myself
because that is impossible
in the book of luke chapter 18
reading verse 18
the book of luke chapter 18
the bible says and a certain ruler asked
him saying good master what shall i do
to inherit eternal life
notice the wording again always read the
bible microscopically
what must i do to inherit
inherit means you receive something from
someone else
and so the rich young ruler understand
he needs to receive salvation from
someone else because he cannot save
himself
the jailer at philippi his question was
what must i do to be saved or to be
saved by someone else
when peter was drowning or sinking in a
weight
in uh matthew chapter 14
in verse 29 the bible says when peter
was come down out of the ship he walked
on the water to go to jesus
when he saw the waves boisterous he was
afraid and beginning to sink he cried
out lord
save me
and the bible says and immediately jesus
stretched his hand and caught him and
said to him o ye of little faith
wherefore this thou doubt so we have
faith involved which means there is a
spiritual application it is by faith
that we're saying that physical
deliverance teaches us a spiritual
lesson it is only god
who can save let me say that again
differently
no created being can save himself
herself or itself
let's drop to itself because animals
don't need to be saved no created being
can save himself
saving is something only god can do
the bible says
in first
timothy chapter four
first timothy chapter four let's read
verse 10
first timothy chapter four reading verse
10 our subject hell for the helpless
the bible says for therefore we both
labor and suffer reproach
because we trust in the living god who
is the savior of all men especially of
those that believe he is the savior of
all men why because we cannot save
ourselves
acts chapter 4 12 there is none other
name under heaven given among men
whereby we must be saved and who is that
name
jesus
christ i have to stress the fact
that only god can save or express
differently
no human being can save himself
not someone like enoch who walked with
god not someone like joshua who told god
let the son stand still not someone like
moses almost face to face with god no
human being can save himself salvation
is a work of god
let me pray again before i continue dear
god
tighten your control on my mind and my
mouth i pray in jesus name amen
in genesis 1 verse 1
genesis 1
verse 1 the bible says
in the beginning
god created the heaven and the earth we
are introduced to this thing called
creation
and we're introduced to who did it and
that person was god
the word for create
in the hebrew is always used of god
and the greek version always of god
because only god can create because
creation in the true sense is bringing
into existence something that had no
prior existence and only god can do that
or making something out of nothing or as
the bible scholars call it ex nihilo out
of nothing
in the beginning
god created
he brought into existence what did not
exist previously
only god
can create that's why particularly in
the old testament god always refers to
creation as the thing which separates
him from all false gods and we talked
about that
last night in our service now
there is physical creation
and there is spiritual creation
and they both function the same way
the bible says if any man be in christ
he's a new
creation or creature in the in the king
james a proper translation creation all
things passed away behold all things
that become new if any man be in christ
any person
that person is a new
creation
that person is a new creature and the
process that brings about that creative
work is the work of god it is as very
the work of god to create spiritually as
it is the work of god to create
physically
when jesus told nicodemus he must be
born again
christ was referring to a process
carried out by the spirit
if you go to john chapter 3 let's read
verse 8 john chapter 3 verse 8
jesus said to nicodemus the wind bloweth
where it listeth and now here is the
sound thereof but can't not tell whence
it cometh or whether it goes so is
everyone that is born of the spirit it
is something that cannot be understood
yet it is a very distinct reality but it
is done by the spirit and the spirit of
course is a divine being creation the
new birth conversion this is a work of
creation it can only be done by god
now
we're told that
christ was the lamb slain from the
foundation of the world we read that in
revelation 13 8 and the same thing is
mentioned in other parts of the bible
the lamb slain from the foundation of
the world
if you read 1st peter 1 verse 28 who
verily was ordained before the
foundation of the world was manifest in
these last times so you this means that
there was a plan to save mankind if
mankind would sin
let's take our minds back to the garden
of eden
adam has sinned
eve has sinned
adam could not save himself
eve could not save herself god knew that
from way back because the plan of
salvation existed before adam and eve
were made in case they sinned god would
have a response the response was jesus
christ would come and die the response
was a savior would come and so when the
angel appeared to joseph the husband of
mary in a dream in matthew 1 21 the
angel gabriel told joseph and she shall
bring forth a son and thou shalt call
his name jesus for he shall save his
people from this sin now simple
reasoning will tell you if god had to
send a savior the simple reason is this
mankind needed to be saved
and mankind could not save itself
let me speak with great respect
for this great directness
your academic degree is precious we
thank god for it it cannot save you
your position in government is important
as it was for joseph in the government
of egypt daniel in the government of uh
babylon and middle persia ezra
it cannot save you
you may be a millionaire we thank god
for wealth all the wealth belongs to god
hagia chapter 2 verse 8 god gives us
power to get wealth it cannot save you
you may have connection with the high
and mighty in your society that cannot
save you the only way to be saved is by
the work of jesus christ and so the
angel told gabriel she shall bring forth
or the angel told joseph
she shall bring forth a son
and thou shalt call his name jesus for
he shall save his people from their sins
jesus alone can save and there is no
other savior but christ we're told this
is not simply the new testament we know
that from the old let us go to isaiah
chapter 45 we'll read verse 22
isaiah 45 verse 22 our subject help
for the helpless
and the helpless that refers to you
and to me
isaiah 45 22 god in heaven continue to
be with me as i address your people for
your glory in jesus name i pray amen
listen to the words very carefully
look unto me
and all the en and be saved all the ends
of the earth
for i am god and there is none else
listen again to the words
look unto me
and be saved all the ends of the earth
for i am god and there is none else what
is the verse saying i am the only one
that can say and that person speaking
was the same one who became flesh in the
new testament that was jesus christ why
because the instant adam saying god no
longer spoke directly to mankind all his
communication was through christ and on
occasions through angels
this is jesus christ speaking
the one who called moses from the
burning bush that was jesus christ the
one who appeared to abraham that was
jesus christ the one who left the
israelites through the wilderness that
was jesus christ even though he was not
called by that name then
and so jesus
the pre-incarnate christ and by
pre-incarnate i mean before he became
human the one who said let there be
light was christ he said and he says to
us
look unto me
and he's talking to you
let me say what i'm about to say very
carefully the church cannot save you
but jesus has a church and you can
identify that church it has identifying
marks but it is not the church that's
saying the church is a place where the
saved go
the church isn't as well let me say
differently the church is a gathering of
the same the church is a gathering of
people who can then advertise that
salvation to others by preaching an
outreach
but the church
cannot save you a church building cannot
save you a collection of human beings
cannot save you only jesus christ and so
jesus says look unto me
and be saved all the ends of the earth
for i am god
and there is none else
now why does he say i am god because
only god can save not gabriel
who is the highest angel he took
lucifer's place when lucifer fell and
became satan the highest angel is
gabriel he was the one who was sent to
daniel he was the one who was sent to
john in the book of revelation he was
the one said to zacharias the father of
john the baptist he was the one sent to
mary unto joseph the earthly parents of
jesus he was he's the angel sent on the
most sensitive missions the highest
angel he cannot save you
look unto me
and be saved all the ends of the earth
for i
am god in other words only god can save
you let's look at that in the new
testament let's go back to matthew
chapter one we'll read 21 and 23 matthew
1 21 and 23
in verse 21 the bible says and she shall
bring forth a son
that's mary and thou shalt call his name
jesus why for he shall save his people
from the sins and so we have someone who
came to the world as a baby that's god
christ
to be a savior verse 23 said a virgin
shall be with child and for brain for
son and they shall call his name
emmanuel which being interpreted is god
with us
look at verse 21 look at verse 23
in verse 21 he has one name
jesus what does it mean
savior the christ the anointed one
in verse 23 he has another name what is
it emmanuel what does it mean god with
us when you combine the two what you're
seeing is that the savior in verse 21 is
god
and i pause for that to sing in
because only god can save
that brings in another consideration
it requires the power of divinity itself
to save someone from sin
it tells us what a terrible and great
power sin is i don't mean to glorify sin
or to glorify the persons who spout the
person whose power is behind sin and
that is satan but it is also essential
that we do not underestimate the power
of sin sin is such a powerful thing that
only god can save you and me from
sin only god
and so the bible says he shall save his
people
from their sins
verse 21 matthew 1 verse 23 his name is
emmanuel god with us only god can
deliver from sin only god can forgive
sins only god can bring about spiritual
creation because creation can only be
done
by
god and so my friends our subject help
for the helpless but having said that
only god can save we also need to
understand you see that's why as i said
that's why jesus came to do what you and
i cannot do for ourselves and that is to
say
but i also need to say very quickly
salvation which can only be done by god
is not forced
salvation
has to be chosen we read in first
timothy chapter 4 verse 10 for therefore
we both labor and suffer reproach
because we trust in the living god who
is the savior of all men what does that
mean does that mean all people will be
saved absolutely not let me explain it
this way
the host church dan harris memorial san
diego central english church in
hyderabad let's use the city of
hyderabad let us assume it has one gas
station as you may see petrol station
one
that petrol station is for all people in
hyderabad
but for those who refuse to go to get
the petrol to put in their cars
it does them no good because they will
not go to that petrol station to receive
what they themselves cannot provide so
if a petrol station in hyderabad the
only one let's assume it is there for
everyone in hyderabad calvary is for
everyone on the earth in that sense
christ is the savior of all men
he has brought salvation made it
available for all but all people will
not come to him to receive it that's why
the verse ends by saying especially
those who are of the household of faith
he especially he's a savior to all
generally he's a savior especially to
those who receive him
let's go back to the genesis
you read verse go to chapter 3
you read from verse 7.
before i continue let me pray again holy
father in heaven continue to be with me
i pray in the name of jesus
let me speak only the words you give to
me i pray in jesus name amen
in verse 7 of chapter 3 of the book of
genesis the bible says and the eyes of
them both were opened
and they knew that they were naked
and they sought fig leaves together
and made themselves april
and they heard the voice of the lord god
walking in the garden in the pool of the
day and adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the lord god
amongst the trees of the garden now
notice the behavior of a lost person
hiding from god it's a tragedy sin is a
true tragedy it's a universal tragedy it
really is the only tragedy and it
produces all kinds of minor tragedies
the parent tragedy is sin
sin
produces in us a behavior contrary to
what god had in mind when he made adam
and eve adam and eve before they sinned
they enjoyed the presence of god
sin created in them a natural urge to
avoid god and so the bible says they
heard the voice of the lord god
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day and adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the lord god
amongst the trees of the garden and the
lord god called unto adam and said unto
him where are thou
and he said i heard thy voice in the
garden and i was afraid because i was
naked and i hid myself i heard but i ran
i heard the truth but i ran i heard the
message that the seven days the sabbath
but i ran i heard the biblical message i
got to return a faithful time but i ran
i heard the message forgive those who
have offended me but i ran i heard the
message respect your church leaders but
i ran people hear the truth and they run
i heard thy voice said adam
at least he was honest on that point
and i hid myself
sin does that
the only power that can change that is
the power of the creator and so god had
to do something
to change adam's mind to change his
attitude towards his creator so that he
would then come to god
the only one who could save him by the
way the one who came down into that
garden was jesus christ
because he is the only mediator between
god and fallen man
and so adam hid and evid
they hid themselves from the only person
who can save them which means that sin
produces a suicidal mindset
let me say that again
sin produces a suicidal mindset because
the person who runs from god is running
from life
in john chapter 5 verse 40 jesus tells
the scribes and pharisees and you will
not come to me that you might have life
because the life we need to make it to
god's kingdom
is given only by god even our physical
life is given by god he will not come to
me that he might have life and adam and
eve had to have a mindset change in
order for them to come to god
john chapter 10 verse 10 jesus said the
thief cometh not but for to steal to
kill and to destroy
i am come that they might have life
because if christ does not bring life no
one can be saved
god had to come
and bring salvation in the person of
jesus christ but we must respond to that
gift of salvation but
even our response there is the work of
god because when we respond to christ we
are really responding to the urging of
the spirit of god because it is not in a
sinner to go to god it is not in the
sinner in and of himself let us go to
romans chapter 3.
romans chapter 3 our subject help for
the helpless romans chapter 3 we shall
read verse 10.
but as it is written
there's none righteous no not one
there's none that understand me there's
none that seeketh after god
we seek pleasures
we seek sin
we seek all sorts of things that hurt
god we do not seek god naturally so the
bible says there's none that
understanding there is none that seeketh
after god this is the condition of the
sinner the sinner needs to be saved but
hates god
the source of salvation let me say it
again it is a terrible condition the
condition of sin the sinner needs to be
saved but the sinner's natural condition
is to avoid god then god must do
something
and this is the love of god in operation
he provides salvation and he also
provides what is required to draw the
synod to him and so jesus said in john 6
44 no man can come to me
except the father which have sent me
draw him and how does god draw us
through the spirit of god and jesus said
in john 6 44 and john 6 65 no one
can come to christ except the father
draws that person and that drawing is
done
by the spirit of god
indeed
there is help
for the helpless
and in god's dealing with adam and eve
we see how god deals with the entire
world he comes
looking for the helpless that he might
save them and so jesus told nicodemus in
luke 18 luke 19 verse 10 the son of man
is come to seek
and to save
that which was lost
to seek unto save that which was lost
in saying that let me say differently
before adam sinned it was god's plan
god's will
that adam and eve and all their
descendants
would live forever
let me say it again
say it differently
death
was not in god's plan for this earth
when he made heaven on earth
there was no death
god's intention was that those who were
born from adam and eve would live
forever god's desire was there would be
no sin on this earth
this because of sin
death enter the world
that is why christ has to come because
salvation is delivered from the curse of
the condemnation which is death or a
cessation of existence whether it's a
death of a person the death of a tree
the death of an animal
sin entered the world and the world
immediately began to deteriorate moving
towards final death thousands of
thousands of years later but inevitably
it would happen because the bible tells
us the earth is like a garment that is
wearing out
salvation is the way by which god
reverses the process of death or
salvation is the way god cancels deaths
let me say it again but let the bible
tell you romans 5
12 wherefore as by one man sin entered
into the world and death by sin and so
death pass upon all men for all have
sinned that's why jesus christ had to
come because his creation came under the
curse of death how by sin and who sinned
it wasn't god
it was adam and eve who sinned and when
they sinned they had the ability to sin
but did not have the ability to deliver
themselves from sin
and so god had to send the same person
who said let there be light the same
person who created heaven and earth was
the one who came to deliver adam and eve
from the curse of sin
salvation is the process by which god
brings us back to the way it was
before sin occurred
that happens
in two stages
but let me say it again
salvation
can be expressed this way it is the
means whereby
god restores what originally was before
sin occurred
otherwise says to restore in man
the image of his maker
to bring him back to the perfection in
which he was created to promote the
development of body and mind and soul
that the divine purpose in his creation
might be realized this was to be the
work of redemption this is the object of
education the great object of life what
is that object to restore in man the
image of his makeup to take creation
back to what it was before sin enter the
world and i said it happens in two
stages the first stage is we must be
recreated in the image of god even while
we're on this earth and we have a sinful
nature
i must say this again
the recreation of the image of god in us
must occur
now
then when christ comes he recreates the
world all over and he puts recreated
people into a recreated world revelation
21 verse 1 i saw a new heaven and a new
earth but before the new heaven and the
new earth are made
new people must be made and the process
by which new inhabitants are made for
the new world is called salvation and
the only person who can do that is the
one who created in the first place and
that is jesus christ so that the creator
is also the savior because when jesus
says he is saving what he made he is
saving what is his
yes it's a beautiful contemplation a
beautiful thought christ in saving you
is saving what is his christ in remaking
this world is remaking what is his
something of his marred by sin but his
love drove him and the father to make a
plan and the plan was he would come
give his life
he would come and suffer
the curse that fell on the earth
and by doing that and coming back from
that which is the resurrection he can
then deliver us from that curse
my brothers and my sisters wherever you
are
god wants to save you
now
i said jesus is the savior and he is the
father is involved as well and so is the
holy spirit by the way all of the
godhead are involved in the salvation of
the soul because we read in john three
verse eight the wind bloweth great
listening and now here is the sound
thereof but can't not tell whence it
cometh or whether it goes so is everyone
that is born in the spirit the actual
process is carried out by the holy
spirit but the bible says for god so
loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son the one who died was jesus
hebrews 9 14 he gave himself the he gave
himself on the cross but who sent him
the father and so we have the father the
son the holy spirit all involved in your
salvation
and in mine
they save us
to place us in a world that will be
recreated and restored to the way it was
before sin entered the world and
temporarily ruined the plans of god
my listening friend
you and i
cannot save ourselves
if we could save ourselves
christ died in vain
let me say it again if we could save
ourselves jesus christ died in vain
we are not saved
by keeping the law of god
by not keeping it we're lost
and i need to say that i'll say it
differently
law keeping does not say it
but law breaking destroys and so we
ought to avoid law breaking and in
avoiding law breaking we choose law
keeping
obeying god's law is not the instrument
of salvation it is merely the life of
the same person
a sick person obeys and that is
obedience to god the only way we are
saved is through the sacrifice of jesus
christ and we receive it by faith
we believe that the death well before
the death the life of christ the
victorious life the sinless life the
life of constantly resisting sin we
accept that we accept the difficult life
he had in his constant struggles of
satan we accept his death his voluntary
death christ gave up his life understand
that clearly he gave up his life we
accept that we believe it we believe he
was in that grave we believe that he
raised himself from the dead we believe
that we believe he is risen he's on the
right hand of god interceding we accept
that as faith we believe that the
sacrifice of jesus christ was enough
enough to pay the penalty of sin when
you receive that into your heart
the instant you do that
you're saved you're justified
now you have to walk and live like a
saved person and that is what is called
sanctification
when the two men went up into the temple
to pray
luke 19
from verse nine to fourteen
a parasit a fabulously republican the
pharisee thought he was mr everything in
the eyes of god he said god i thank thee
i'm not as any men are
you know extortionist unjust adulterers
or even as this republican i fast twice
in the week i give tithes of all that i
possess
you know verse 11 and 12 of matthew of
luke 19 or luke 18.
the public
that's a sinner
standing afar off would not lift up so
much as his eyes unto heaven but small
upon his breast saying god
be merciful to me
a sinner
in this short statement he recognized he
could not save himself
he recognized he was a sinner
he recognized he needed an act of mercy
and he recognized the source of that
mercy was god and he bowed he said you
would not look up a consciousness of his
condition he said god be merciful to me
a sinner that prayer must be the prayer
of everyone who wants to be saved but he
recognized that the only person who
could save him was god and he accepted
what god had provided jesus said in
verse 14 of luke 18 i tell you this man
went down to his house justified rather
than the other what does justify mean
made right with god
being saved
is accepting a man who is also god as
the one who can deliver you from the
curse of sin which is death being saved
is receiving a person into your life and
believing that what he did is all that
is required to save you salvation is
believing with all your heart and soul
and mind and strength and might and
understanding on what a man who's also
god did
and what he did
is express in his life
his death
his resurrection
help
for the helpless
right where you sit
if you believe you're not saved
that can change the instant you say god
come
save me as peter wrote lord save me as
the republican said god be merciful to
be the sinner you can say god be
merciful to me with the consciousness
that you cannot save yourself but you
need to be saved you cannot deliver
yourself from the curse of sin which is
death you ask god to do that and you
make that request with all your heart
and soul
why do i say all your heart and soul
when philip preached to the ethiopian
unit in acts chapter eight in verse 36
and as they went on the way they came up
on a certain water and the the unit said
see here is water what does hinder me to
be baptized and philip said if thou
believeth with all thine heart
thou mess with all the heart belief
jesus said in mark 11 23 verily i say
unto you whosoever shall say to this
mountain be removed and be thou cast
into the sea and shall not doubt in his
heart but shall believe those things
which you say shall come to pass he
shall have what he said jesus says do
not doubt when he saved peter in a
matthew chapter 14 in verse 30 peter
said god saved me the bible says verse
31 immediately jesus stretched forth his
hand and caught him and said oh now of
little faith wherefore why did you doubt
don't doubt says jesus christ don't
doubt
because that cancels whatever god is
trying to do god does not reward doubt
doubt cancels what jesus christ can do
and so i'm saying you simply say with
everything that's in you dear god
i'm a sinner
i come and i give my life to you
save me
do for me what you sent your son to do
save me and you see it with all your
heart
the moment you do that
and you say it with all your heart and
soul
you're saved
you justify
from that point on you renew that
surrender and you live the righteous
life and the way to live that life is
laid out for you and for me in the word
of god help
for
the helpless
without god
we're helpless what does jesus say john
15 4 abide in me and i in you
as the branch cannot bear fruit of
itself except it abide in the vine no
more can ye accept you abide in me
i am the fine
here the branches he that abideth in me
and i in him the same bringeth forth
much fruit for without me he can do
nothing now without god we can do
nothing this is physical and spiritual
you're listening to me
whatever makes you hear me is controlled
by the power of god because he upholds
all things by the word of his power so
physically and spiritually we're
dependent upon god
but particularly spiritually
without knee you can do nothing
give that life to christ
he alone can save you
when you give him his life
no one can pluck you from his hand
not satan and all the evil angels come
by
no one can tuck you from the hand of
christ
it is a glorious thing when the spirit
of god brings us to the place when we
recognize we are helpless in the sense
that we cannot save ourselves
we thank god that the spirit continually
nudges us and convicts us
and tries to move us towards the point
of total surrender to god because he
alone through his son
can save us
may god bring that conviction into your
life if you need it
that christ is the only one who can save
you and may the restless work of the
spirit of god bring you to the place
where you say like the lord save me
where you say like republican god
be merciful to me a sinner because in
christ
we have help
for the helpless let us pray
our father in heaven we thank you for
your word
we thank you thank god for the plan of
salvation
we thank you for jesus who is the
personification of that plan we thank
you father
all that is necessary for our salvation
and growth
may be found
in jesus christ
he's our wisdom
he's our redemption he's our
sanctification he's our righteousness
he's our light
he's our bread
he's our shepherd he's our everything to
us dear god
we thank you for that
we thank you that he's a man even not
who can understand us we thank you he's
also god who can do something
for us
in the name of jesus christ there god
receive us as we recommit our lives to
you and for that man that woman
listening to me who needs to make a
surrender that person who needs to make
that surrender may have been a church
member for years but father we need to
understand we can be church members
without knowing jesus but we cannot be
children of god without knowing christ
father i must repeat these words some of
us need to understand we can be members
of the church our names on the books
without knowing jesus but to be a child
of god we must have christ in the light
so there may be someone who has been a
church member but by behavior has not
been a child of god talk to that person
that god that he or she may make that
surrender again i ask you pour out a
special blessing and the little boys and
little girls thank god let them feel the
urge to give their lives to you another
special blessing on all our guests who
are listening their father heal those
who are sick with kovalev 19 restore
them to help their god and let that
expression of goodness draw them close
to you bless the host church in a very
special way let the presence of that
church and hide that or bad be the
reason why many will be ready to meet
christ when he comes father bless them
as they return for tonight be with me as
i go through the day bring us back
tomorrow according to your will in jesus
name we pray amen
you